can I run as fast as Tom Cruise let's
find out now if this looks familiar it's
because I've already done enough stupid
things while running including running
an entire 5K while wearing screen
accurate stormtrooper armor but I
recently watched the trailer for Mission
Impossible 7 and I saw Tom Cruise a 60
year old man running faster than I've
seen any 60 year old run before now sure
he's fast but is he faster than me
probably I'm gonna be attempting to run
as fast as Tom Cruise in this scene from
Mission Impossible 3 barreling through
the streets of jitang at over 15 miles
per hour almost as fast as some
professional sprinters Tom Cruise has
been running a movie since 1981
according to his personal Instagram
account and despite whatever you may
think of him in his personal life the
dedication he shows toward his craft is
outmatched by basically no one he does
all of his own stunts including jumping
a motorcycle off of a Cliff dangling
from the side of an airplane in the sky
climbing the side of the Burj Khalifa
flying in real F-18 fighter jets holding
his breath for seven minutes underwater
performing a real 25 000 foot halo jump
and breaking his shin right here before
finishing the take most of all although
he runs
[Music]
over the past month I've been studying
Tom Cruise and is running in films
throughout his career the veteran actors
had a running scene in all but eight of
his movies eight movies out of 51 acting
credits and some initial Studies have
shown that when Tom Cruise runs in a
film it actually performs better at the
box office but that's a rabbit hole to
go down a different time Cruz claimed he
could run at 17 miles per hour when he
was younger which likely could get him
close to Collegiate level athlete speed
with some training
[Music]
years old in the film he runs at full
speed along a river in the town of
jiteng in China and the camera follows
alongside him while he's running the
scene contains a number of vertical
wooden pillars which provide useful
reference points for estimating his
speed to find out exactly how fast he
was running I captured a frame whenever
Crews passed a wooden pillar stitched
the frames together and noted the time
between pillars which gives us this
diagram based on this we'll find that he
runs at an average speed of 6.85 meters
per second or 15.32 miles per hour
therefore in his film performance Cruise
exhibits really fast running but he's
not a world-class Runner which means I
might have a chance but first I need to
see if I'm even able to get my running
top speed up to 15 miles an hour to
match Tom's average speed luckily I know
of a speed sign near my house to help
gauge just how fast I am I have to be
able to run 15 miles an hour if I'm
gonna run as fast as Tom Cruise
oh my gosh it's already recording us
here we go
[Music]
I don't know how he does that multiple
ticks I'm already tired just because I
can get up to 15 miles per hour though
doesn't mean that I can maintain that
speed 100 meters would be a lot more
difficult and I'd have to run it in
under 14.6 seconds to match Cruz's time
in Mission Impossible three three two
one go
good
what was it 12.18 oh easy money Tom I
got you beat but real question can I do
it in jeans like she does
three
two
foreign
dude I'm still faster than Tom Cruise
which isn't saying much because he's
like 60. it's not fun
Mission possible even though I beat his
time he was wearing long pants and
normal shoes and he was in his 40s and
shouting Mandarin at people to get out
of the way and he got paid more than
most of us will ever see in our lives
for doing it I think it's pretty obvious
that Tom even in his 40s completely
outmatches me in the athletic department
and I'm just 24. one thing's for certain
though I never want Tom to stop running
run Tom run
oh
[Music]